welcome back to the fives labor day
special we are answering more of your
fan mail questions okay first up nancy t
what's one of your favorite movie
soundtracks tyrus
who uh you know what i'm gonna go with
because if i go classic i mean i think
everyone would be empire strikes back or
scarface but uh recently i've tried what
i just saw a black widow with with my
kids and the soundtrack they took old
nirvana songs and some kind of creepy
and i was like you know what this is
pretty that's cool so i bought the
soundtrack so i agree uh so that's how i
connect with my kids cause i'm still hip
you know what i'm saying you sure so
cool
dana frozen i'm kidding oh you're not
you're not own it it's okay i saw this
guy the other day i was very cute if
you've seen these um
car seats for kids bicycle seats for
kids and it's they're in the front like
so behind them and here's this guy
a little girl
in the seat with her helmet on he's got
his own and he is blasting on his bike
the soundtrack to frozen for her which
was adorable um
i'll date myself a little bit i love the
grease
yes absolutely
um jessie well first let me just throw
my belt up here
see but if you had a big enough shoulder
you could just take your hands away just
stay there you got to get those traps
upside down i gotta how about that
doesn't look as cool now it looks like
you have an injury yeah it's got a
broken wing
i was gonna go
rocky i have a tiger that fires you up
inspirational sure for sure and geraldo
what about you
i'd go again this is generational i go
to lawrence of arabia
dr zhivago
uh i i ain't even gone with the wind i
know no one's allowed to watch it
anymore does that cancel out
there's gonna be a thing in the
beginning of it uh lord of the rings
lord of the rings is a great soundtrack
absolutely
[Laughter]
should we go on to the second question
okay
facebook question from barbara l and she
asks how many oh how many states in the
united states have you been to which
state did you enjoy visiting the most oh
let's go around the table this way i've
been in all states every state
every every city i'm like the uh johnny
cash song
you've been everywhere everywhere i've
been in every i've been
and uh do which one do i like the best
impossible question i think i've had
good times everywhere uh the mountain
west
uh but the southwest very dramatic also
and you know i'm a city boy this is my
town yes and i just love it here
i've been to 48 out of the 50.
not election
and one of the dakotas i don't remember
which one where is sturgis south south
so i haven't been to north dakota okay
and
my favorite probably hawaii oh yeah
classic answer yes classic answer okay
what about 49 i also have not been to
north dakota okay so maybe we should
take this show on the road one of these
days and get there a great people up
there in north dakota my favorite one
i'll say wyoming for sure absolutely yes
i love why that might be my favorite
state too what about you tyler i have
been suck up dakota i went pheasant
hunting out there in college it's it's a
great place snow is good well i've been
everywhere but alaska and uh i kept
missing out on the tours in wwe alaska i
always got sent you went pheasant
or any other kind of critter hunter and
alaska is a beautiful state yeah i got
it on my bucket list i've been all the
way from uh the arctic circle down
you've been all the territories too all
the territory guam oh yeah well you know
i sailed my brother i've ever been to
puerto rico overall
own plenty of great place territory
there i love puerto rico puerto rico is
actually i'm halfway there
did you know that you are everyone in
puerto rico thought i was puerto rican
and they cheered me i didn't zoom out
okay we got to hear from kelly v she
says who inspired you to be on tv jesse
oh
the factor inspired me he unleashed me
onto this country so you have him to
blame for me
we love it we love that it happened dana
what about you it's coming interesting
when i was a kid growing up in colorado
i believe her name was paula woodward
and she was a local um of course i don't
remember which channel it was i want to
say abc but it might have been nbc um so
i would say yeah paula woodward i
thought she did investigative reporting
great it was good what about you tyrus
oh i got two in an interesting career
richard pryor and the american dream
dusty roads two guys got on the mic and
just told it like it was and i would
just stand there and be like i need to
do that i want to do that you're not as
filthy as richard pryor oh just because
we're here but give me a
go see a stand-up of mine sometimes yeah
or see me in traffic we'll do that after
pheasant hunting yes
you want to go we'll go i want to go and
geraldo i'm sure you've inspired many
people to be on tv what about you i did
not have a tb through most of my life
and certainly not in college
and i don't recall ever seeing any
reporter work
i was discovered as a lawyer
and someone said hey kid you want a job
and it was wabc here in new york and
they sent me to colombia and it all
started there that was uh awesome
what about you carly well um
i told this story the last time that i
did one of these specials i mean i
watched fox and friends when i was in
high school but then my first job here
was being imus's assistant where i met
you
and watching imus do the legendary radio
thing
made me continue on to do radio and just
be a part of this i'm so glad you
survived yeah you should have stayed in
radio god bless him oh jessie why is
that nasty oh i'm just teasing her
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else